good morning everyone I just realized I
forgot to put on my jewelry
well you rang your ring that's all that
matters is the first time for everything
and yesterday's first time for
everything I forgot my ring a trouble in
paradise oh yeah big time good morning
Millennials today is Wednesday June 27
I'm going to Chicago tomorrow got Windy
City I'm looking forward to the cool
breeze like flowing up my skirt you know
you can't wear a skirt while you're
there no definitely not even though
everything it's called a hot it's still
windy like I can't believe that I have a
new neck and I'm doing a show in Chicago
and like it's still not healed it's
pretty much healed the pain I was
whipping my hair like working overtime
at this engagement party last night and
I think I pulled your neck yeah that
already be separate from and you know
what it was I did glam squad which I'll
go into in a minute and I told her I'm
like I did makeup because I can't do my
own makeup because my face is so sore I
was like please go gentle of course she
did not go gentle well it looked good
yeah no oh my god beauty is pain truly
truly and Jeana that glam squad now who
does manicures yes so this is the second
time I've done it I've been
overwhelmingly pleased both times which
like never happens to me
and I just had like an amazing hair
makeup and nail person yesterday like
things couldn't have been going more of
my way and I don't know what like came
over me I just decided to like call glam
squad I'm like let them know that I was
pleased because I'm always complaining
totally know me there's I'm always
getting refunds I always have credits
cuz like every time I don't like it I
call and like I'm so annoying and I
think my account has like a star for VIP
on it so like they know I'm like a diva
so I just felt like being like a good
customer and calling and the woman great
like that's the experience you're
supposed to have yeah I mean I told her
to leave a note on my account that like
in the future when I book if any of
these new people are available like
holler at me I don't think there's
anything lazier than an at-home manicure
I said I was telling the lady she was
listening but I was like lately like
ever since I got because I used to like
go out for blowouts and then like blow
that's what started coming to me so like
I didn't need to go out for blowouts but
I always still went out for a manicure
like even like on the laziest days of
the year I would take ten minutes to get
like a back rub in a massage I don't
even do that anymore
well to each their own I got a manicure
esterday the normal
cute okay my favorite summer color
bikini so teeny oh I got a new favorite
color because my glam squad brought it
to my house I've colored a you color I
had the same color that I pull out of my
drawer and she's like you want to use
this color yeah it's called gogo geisha
it's lovely if you're a married woman it
looks really nice for the ring or
engaged and she pulled out this like
slew of Essie and I'm like no I'd bring
my own but she had this color it's
called island-hopping and I just wanted
it on Amazon I always bring my own nail
polish very important I hate when people
ask me what color my house is because I
never have any clue unless it's like
this one I don't know the name of it no
I'm like I'm I'm a die-hard like the way
people rule rule the way people root for
like sports teams I root for nail colors
like I stand nail colors and you know
what I decided yesterday I forgot to
tell you this the toast is gonna
officially stand be be Rexha why I love
her I think she's in my category now of
stands I just
I think she's epic I love that she is
like not so skinny she is like a big ass
and she sings best song of all time
like literally written I like her she
has good songs but she's not
accomplished enough to be obsessed with
like does she even have an album no but
the cool thing about being a stance and
you're like you're there for the growth
you know for sure so like but I don't
think you can like totally stand someone
until they have a whole catalogue that
you can get behind a few good songs does
not escape forget about me myself and I
anyways before we end this in the Fast
Five stories we need to know you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of here anyhow keeping up so many
housekeeping announcements I'm seeing
some concerned comments about cam
toasting me to Rosh Hashanah Rosh
Hashanah is Sunday night we have to be
out of camp toast Sunday morning at
10:00 a.m. busses we're wheels up of cam
toast 10:00 a.m. on Sunday assuming it
happens knock on wood so you were
talking about it so much and like I just
know it's not gonna happen like that but
when I'm talking to the director of the
camp he's talking as if it's already
happening so now it's like I mean do you
want this or anything it's not an if in
my dreams it's already happened like
three summers in a row and look I wasn't
color war both time no but he's not
saying if we can make it happen he's
like so we're making it happen and do
you want this this or this
like it's happening it's happening but
like I'm so agree that one's gonna
derail it I know but you will be home in
time for Arab Russia Shana
don't worry and second we are go
to start on Thursday because people were
worried about getting into late Friday
night so now everyone come in Thursday
afternoon to Thursday night and then we
have the whole day Friday for color war
and if you want to keep Shabbos you
totally have oh it's encouraged it's
take everyone's phone so I know because
the toast is so what's the worst idea
ever it's so campy no no I'm literally
like I just can't and I've been thinking
a lot about color war because obviously
we're gonna have to do it that like I
have one team you know the other team of
course and we both have different
strengths you know when it comes to
physical physicality like you got that
when it comes to sheer you know um
charisma and team spirit it's totally me
I use agree I'm so spirited and like no
offense Oh like I just feel like you're
quick to give up oh okay
first of all we all know that in real
camp I was general and I did win so
let's just not for nothing not without
sharding nothing that was a different
color war now for nothing experienced
experienced just is everything everyone
knows that like experience is just you
need experience for sure
first of all second of all I've been to
three camps and participated in three
different types of color war therefore
I'm trained to any type of color war or
Olympics whether it's a three-day sport
or one camp we went to it lasted the
whole summer that was crazy
it was like a little unnecessary it was
like you got your teams in the beginning
of the summer and every weekend you
would compete and who at all tally up
but really unlike the last day did that
was really competitive and then you were
always like competing with your button
like highly unnecessary now that I think
about it yeah I think it was just a
competitive camp yeah and they just
wanting you everyone was like skinning
it on speed this is totally and we're
gonna continue planning cam toes we'll
give you updates as we have them and by
the way I just want to say look I've
gotten so many emails and like dm's of
people like me channel trying to help
plant the camp toast and I just think
that it's great it's really it's really
kind thank you but so far we're good
we're full steam ahead and we have
everything under control we need to like
make water bottles and stuff though no
we need t-shirts like for color war yeah
but also like everyone need to water
bother you gotta stay hydrated
that's true we can't have anyone dying
of dehydration on our hands the
liability oh oh god okay are you ready
for the fast five stories you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast sure first
stories actually kind
interesting Pete Davidson asked an
France from queer I'd helped dress him
for his wedding I read about this this
morning and so cute so cute so in tune
with what's necessary honestly because
Pete Davidson I wouldn't consider him
like a style icon just an article about
Pete Davidson's penis and it's either
like huge or really small I couldn't
like I couldn't want to read the whole
thing and the headline wasn't giving it
away like big dick energy yes yeah did
you I saw it and I didn't read it
not a big dick energy for sure thank you
you have big dick the biggest butt so no
I have big ball energy so does that mean
that you have actually a big dick just
read the funniest thing in tipsy
toasters literally the Facebook subgroup
tipsy toasters where they people just
talk about how much I love to drink is
my favorite subgroup aside from the
friends one and this girls put a
screenshot she's like a bottle girl at a
club and like for the first time ever
she went home with one of her patrons
and he was like a bet like a football
player she wouldn't say his name but he
definitely lives in Philly so he's a
terrorist and she posted a screenshot of
like their text messages afterwards like
I didn't know what she was gonna say
she's like I just had a burning question
for him what why do you have one ball
and it's a you know it's a work-related
injury so she thought that but it's very
normal Steve Stewie I think that's the
only one no it's a very common problem
and I'm sure prosthetics have way
advanced too since Brady was looking for
one yeah not Brady Steve C Frady yeah I
need these to Brady's really to Tom
Brady definitely not definitely not
they couldn't have more different
annotation no one won a big dick energy
and 100 Appa someone has one ball energy
um anyway close our show today
totally Pete Davidson wants to be sure
he looks his very best when he ties the
knot with Ariana Grande
so he's enlisted the help of queer eye
fashion expert tan Franz to prep his
wedding wardrobe Franz 35 told page six
he'll absolutely be assisting with the
24 year old SNL stars attire for the big
day he asked if I'd help him the answer
is yes it's really crazy because when I
think of Pete and Ariana getting engaged
like I don't think that means they're
getting married I couldn't agree more
so the fact that there's a wedding in
the works there's no buyers his wardrobe
is crazy no what's crazy is like how
famous the queer eye people are and I
think there's a divide a schism you
think yes between everyone and then
Bobby
tomorrow Kurama I always say his name
wrong sorry tan Anthony tan and jbn are
like best friends and they like are like
lovers like they just are obsessed with
each other and Bobby like doesn't hang
and neither does Crum oh maybe it's
because they're both in relationships
but that's just what I heard on the
streets and then the photos proved it no
man they think about this one tan and
Anthony are always hanging out together
and with like Gigi Hadid and I just want
to say that when we saw a little mix in
concert I made a really good call about
that girl Jess I like if they ever break
up it's because that girl Jessica feels
left out and like it's gonna be like a
whole thing and that's what's gonna
happen to it that it's been five years
since you said that things take time I
don't think so it's gonna happen you
guys I know it Little Mix they just
wrote a new song that is so good and
it's like oh I was concocting a tweet
the other day that I ended up not
tweeting because like I feel like people
are gonna come for me but it was about
fifth harmony and they were like it was
like it was the day that fits her buddy
ended and it was like a stat for like
one of these like Twitter accounts about
how they're like the biggest girl group
in the world know one of the biggest
girl groups in the world it's like
there's only two that's not like we're
we're included in that - totally why did
it's not prestigious what's
controversial about saying that will the
Harmonizers like what like you can't say
anything bad because I'm trying to
Twitter there's something bad about mom
let me ask you yesterday oh my god you
were so just if I believed but thank you
I just want to get to the bottom of this
okay saying there's only two groups
you're saying so it's fifth harmony and
Little Mix right yes so why would the
Harmonizers come for you because they
think I'm like belittling the
accomplishments of a girl group and I'm
not here for girls who don't support
other girls you're not doing either of
those things it's a fad I was just
seeing the facts like don't I was like
they're hyping up this statistic and the
statistic isn't that impressive seeing
as how there's literally only two famous
girl groups I'm trying to think I was
thoroughly googling girl groups and the
last one was Destiny's Child like I
think they were talking about that
no harmony is not working loose and now
there's only one little mix I guess they
are the number one girl group oh they're
number one girl in this group oh and
also actually be we're exes damn thing
that's not even what I wanted to say I'm
back to standing 5 seconds of summer
good me and then it used to be obsessed
the
we went to their concert in Jones Beach
and we were truly the oldest people
there and we had front-row seats because
like these concerts for kids are like
not expensive because kids can't pay a
lot of money except like when they they
get to like One Direction level but so
many a Bentley paid $100 we had
literally front-row seats and we were
like what's that thing called lent you
like head Bob yeah but you know and then
I just kind of gave up on them for a
while and I was always thinking up on
themselves they stopped putting out
music because you want to know what they
did I read this whole thing on them they
started writing for like simple plan and
like old like Joel Madden like old 90s
bands and that like have lost their way
because they're like really talented
like songwriters yeah then they took a
break and I was I had my glam squad over
yesterday and they don't wanna put on
country music cuz I was feel awkward
putting on country music when like other
people are in my house yeah so they put
on like Spotify top and this song was
putting I'm like this is a banger 5
seconds of summer when song my heart
felt bleed heart no they are new song
it's on my clean list hold on it's
called like blood lie to me um it's over
the heart love blood on I'm gonna tell
you
blood beside heartfelt some like that
huh lie to me no that's the one that I
like that's a new song I'm glad they're
putting out new music me too and they're
hot and like there's a lot of drama
what do you mean like I don't know
something on the bun told you blood he
said what I drama I don't know I just
follow them on Twitter there's like
always drama what does that mean mm-hmm
it was just how much there's always
between who the members or like them
against the world just trauma like girl
drama like one of them was engaged to
that girl who I'm follow me on Instagram
and used to date Leonardo DiCaprio and
you know Brianna Holly I don't know her
and they were engaged in like the fans
were not okay like they didn't think she
was a good girl and I think they were
right
told you drama that's crazy I'm really
hot today could you imagine if the fans
like did like Ben oh my god I'm so funny
that'd be hilarious oh my goodness okay
well anyways I'm glad that 10 is
dressing Pete for his wedding and I hope
that there is a wedding like I want to
see Bridal ariana grande honestly I just
don't think P David's in a marriage
material
really do you think Ariana Grande is
there
so yeah and like that when I saw her in
a dress at the Met Gala I was like this
is weird cuz she's always wearing like
spandex and like boots I just don't see
her in a wedding dress she would have to
wear like a thigh high wedding dress no
yes she would wear like that black dress
that she wore to the BB Emmys mm-hmm but
like in white dress boots okay maybe she
should get married and he was also there
like our age so I'm saying I'm saying
that they're young like yeah but like
were mature for our age that's - that's
true can you tell that I got a blowout
last night like know how disappointing
I'm sweating my ass off at this
engagement party but working overtime
for the bride and groom and what's a
bracket that comes at a price yeah yeah
yeah that's the real downside was like I
left my house feeling like a legit of
real housewives we got a Town Car in
uber and there was like this thing in
between us so I really felt like Kyle
Mauricio like on my way to pick up Lisa
Vanderpump and I was just feeling my
luck like I was wearing this like mature
dress that was like below the knee mm-hm
and I don't know I just have like this
glam that was really pleased with and
like I took a million pictures and like
I don't know her I don't know the girl
missile yeah
I had the same experience very upset I
got dressed and I looked really cute a
spring dress and we were in that
neighborhood of like Central Park for
like five hours yeah because we had to
be there earlier in the day and then we
went to a lovely housewife dinner at
Audra Madison so I feeling like a
housewife everyone thought they saw
Tommy I just seen on my story I don't
know if it was him but like I took a
picture of like the pretty tree and it
looks like there's time in the
background it probably was head we'll go
check because he would go eat there I
will check and then we went to the bar
at the peninsula it was just like such a
day and then I made exact take a bunch
of pictures of me in the park and like
I'd never that's totally him really
totally even though he looks like he
gained a little weight actually I take
it back
it's not him I didn't thinking he looks
way older and Tom is completely bald and
that guy has a little white hair on the
back of his head that's true
yeah I but I if I and Zach would have
noticed if it was time cuz as we're
leaving the peninsula so I've noticed
Ramona getting into her car dead and I
missed her anyways if I would say I made
Zack take a million pictures of me in
the park like where could be a better
place for a picture where I'm wearing my
Sunday finest dress looking cleany and
I've never looked worse so I just
hardening like I'll show you these
pictures after like I put up one that is
so facetune
it's not even remotely close to the
original and I'm not even barest to say
that cuz like I just wanted to put up a
picture I saw the baby my friends
engagement but like not at my own what
price you know she posed it took one's
you know I just did an interim story I
was i I had a posted I wanted to post on
a club but no job I was like no I'm
definitely have an amazing photo from
this engagement party tonight cut to six
hours later I'm like working overtime
for like some shitty blurry picture I
literally like made the picture more
blurry so you couldn't see what it looks
like
that's so funny very unfair well we
appreciate the honesty and you know what
happens solemn and now just like go get
a picture of me and honor from high
school and they put it on my Instagram
like Congrats congratulating her like
even though I wanted like a glam shot
from the rooftop engagement party yeah
honestly I don't know about a high
school I know unless you'd like a great
shot that I shot she's like one of my
oldest friends so we had like the oldest
photos together yeah which is cute yeah
it's like you four people who know us
not for like my public Instagram you
know I agree okay next up in riveting
News Grammys are two increased nominees
and top categories from five to eight so
more blood yoga are much and I already
feel like the the Grammys were like way
too opened you know what I mean it's
like not that hard to get a Grammy
anymore no I agree and after last year's
Grammy nominations and I was not in tune
with any of them this is just even
though Bruno Mars swept the entire thing
right but denomination's like yeah I
don't know anyways I don't need more
mediocrity but thank you know I couldn't
be more like I just think it's always
like every time there's the Grammys and
like even though I stand her like bebe
Rexha shows up like she not need not be
at the Grammys like she's not there yet
so I just think it's all ready to open
yeah and like too thirsty and - trying
to make fetch happen and like their
whole thing is like collaborations that
you you ever knew that like open Jon
like Miley which was great which is
amazing but they were collaborating on
their own yeah the Grammys just picked
them up know like like dnce and Rod
Stewart okay but like sometimes know
with is like the Marin Mersenne Alicia
Keys singing her song yes that was epic
that's when everyone fell in love with
Marin arts and I was like please you
guys I've known her for years
yeah and she had long hair and everyone
thought she look like Jojo Fletcher or
when they did Taylor Swift at Miley
Cyrus like a years ago singing 15 oh my
god I didn't remember that it was it was
something or 15 but see here's the thing
the Grammys are getting too muddled for
me because like here's the thing what's
the thing Taylor Swift like Grammys is
like besides for the awards they're like
this musical institution they're like a
non-profit we're like they give all
their money like music education and
like yes it's like the SAG kind of um I
think the word sag is funny and so
Taylor Swift like has like a scholarship
there she gives a lot of money she's
like a Grammy exhibit in the museum like
I don't know it just seems like she's
paying her way to the top like a college
you know yeah you know that's like when
the dumb kid gets in but like there's a
wing in his name yes but I feel like I
said she's deserving I'm not calling you
a dumb kid and we say you want to hear a
fascinating statistic sure that's gonna
be a fascinating transition uh Demi
Lovato has never won a Grammy says juju
Elizabeth so better be true here's the
thing good like she's like she's not
like an artiste
maybe now she'll be nominated for like
sober but like just as far as I know
Justin Bieber has won Grammys okay
Justin Bieber songs are amazing
I think Demi Lovato songs her know there
are this good is Justin around the same
level no not at all what depth like
honestly Jaime's album was great like
for me like to listen to in my house
like not on a Grammy level like Justin
Bieber songs took over the world like to
ignore them would be just like blatant
disregard for respect you know I feel
like that's scene in Legally Blonde when
she's like using all those terms that
don't exist to get the dog back yeah
evidentiary litigation yeah that's me
I'm taking the dog dumbass okay well
anyways congrats to all the nominees
future nominees who they did even though
they don't deserve it John levon got
nominated for a Grammy did he win no no
he did not win and he was robbed I think
I'm on all the time okay you guys and
there is no cliques we've never sold on
it and I'm seeing yesterday I mean never
smelled it as a Netflix original movie
called the Polka King where and it's not
poker it's polka I thought was hoping to
ha I started watching because I thought
I was like a movie back gambling but
it's not Jack Black plays it's a true
story this guy called John levon he is
an immigrant from Poland he comes to
America for a better life as many people
do and he makes this Empire of polka
music but there's like some there's
another layer to it I don't want to ruin
it for you Black Jack is
amazing in the movie watch what you just
said blackjack poker black what does he
Jack Black Jack Black is amazing in the
movie it's such a good movie so many
classic lines that we can't even say
that was no no were talking about
literally and no nobody's seen this
daddy that was you I think Jack Black is
like a really trying to become a serious
actor like after Kung Fu Panda and this
was like his way and it's such a good
movie
it's a good movie it's such an
interesting story and you know what got
me thinking about it because of the oh
wait Thank You Maegan views Bieber and
Taylor sell out or we stadiums while
Demi is still doing arenas so
interesting like she's just not there
yet that doesn't surprise me but then
also on the other hand it's like is the
Grammys about popular music or like
musical music both in the words of Kanye
West I hear you got a sell it to smash
the Grammy so it's a lot about sales it
should be but also about like musical
candor and it should be but whatever
what we young live on you know what got
me thinking about it because there's
been interest in people like investing
in the toast oh my god and I was just
like we could be Yamaha and when I
thought about taking and I'm like no I
would go down a dark hole and I wouldn't
fire all the right paperwork like a
Yamla ba just watch this movie today and
we're we kept tomorrow we've never led
you astray with Netflix original movies
I did not recommend the set up this is
very different than what we usually
recommend but it is so interest it's a
little similar to the kissing booth
unbelievable and the way that he gets
caught with the yeah and all the true
stories raising if it wasn't a true
story we would reason why we're talking
about this because he is a polka band
that becomes really famous in like a
small town of Philadelphia and they get
nominated for a Grammy and he gets to go
into the polka category we should really
like it's like there's a lot of random
categories that don't get announced on
like air but that like and like liberal
lunch in the day before and like we
could totally do that
yeah I feel like there's definitely some
sort of audio maybe storytelling podcast
Grammy yeah like Joan Rivers won a
posthumous Grammy for her comedy album I
am coming
this is coming okay we could do it we
just got a report it we got in the
studio I loved getting in this you need
to okay next up we have a doubleheader
to bachelor in paradise stories the
first one is great
for Claudia and bad news for Derrick and
Taylor bachelor in paradise is Taylor
Nolan and Derrick paths split we are
quote heartbroken Derrick path and
Taylor Mullen have called it quits their
statement says it is was much sadness
that we have decided to end our
engagement we put everything we could
into our relationship and our
heartbroken to go forward separately but
we know this is the best decision for
the both of us we will still be present
in each other's lives with support
admiration and respect for each other at
the end of the day it just came down to
the fact that Derrick was not over at
the direct messages he received from
girl with no jobs Claudia Shea
he reread them every night before he
went to sleep and Taylor could no longer
live with the guilt and the shame okay
so many things this Damon was totally
written by mental health counselor named
Taylor mocha I don't even know her real
last name one - I'm like I had forgotten
about them and I forgot about my love of
Derek and like now that they broke up
it's all I can think about no I mean
he's like John Krasinski eyebrows I love
him I want more of him and I'm just like
when they're not engaged I was like I
was working so hard to be happy for them
but like it shouldn't be that or
something in the back of your mind them
stopping you it's those gems wow this is
just really exciting I think you should
reach out obviously I don't know that
you're here for him okay so I was
thinking of reaching it straight but I
don't want to be like two pounds see
like and honestly like my real goal is
to get him on the show so like I can't
be like sleuthy like I have to wait like
a good amount of time I'm sure they've
been working out for a while but I was
aware to the text Olivia Creedy and
asked her like what the real story is
good enough and now she's hanging out
with Taylor even though like Olivia and
Derek have history yeah so drama so
that's how I figured that they were
broken up cuz why would I don't feel it
ectopy like would be two years for
Olivia to be hanging out with Taylor
when she's engaged to a man okay
yeah they do
okay are you sure I'm pretty sure and
even if they don't they do it down
anyways so sorry this is like sad cuz
they were the only engagement from last
yeah so now like there's so much hinging
on Raven and Adam and I think that they
can handle the pressure
I think they can too because true love
can hold any barrier and they're so true
so they are true Tristan does he still
work true Thompson who Adam I believe I
believe so too she works there really
like
making a real go ahead their modern
couple and everyone could learn
something from them couldn't there the
modern teen in Tanner
even though they couldn't be more modern
yeah except they don't live in like a
palace in Kansas right but would you
rather live in a palace in Kansas or for
the same price like a studio in New York
honestly palace again no but like we've
chosen I know if I didn't have such deep
roots in my community here I would move
to a palace in Kansas in ten seconds but
this thing about your deeper it's here
and they're the same roots is mine like
we can uproot them and plant them
somewhere else like we're just each
other's roots do you know I mean I have
like a little bit more of like a develop
to root didn't you I think like I'm
really deeper it's what a community my
shul my synagogue why are you talking
about I'm a big member of the community
so I'm saying you could start a new
community and you could it be an even
bigger member we need because he would
be the founder we need to live near a
major city though like right outside
Nashville Franklin that's where we need
to live live sure
wherever I'm too frequent like literally
I just might maybe there you go
I'm ready to go like I'm standing here
if we outside your door
if the scenes are like we're ready to go
like my bags are packed you don't have
to convince me wake you up to say
goodbye okay and yeah you don't forget a
music producer could be listening to the
Today Show take it away cuz the dawn is
breaking it's certainly more the taxis
waited he's blowing his horn to a ready
I'm so lonesome I could die so kiss me
and smile for me tell me that you wait
for me oh me like you'll never let me go
it's all so sad it is I feel like we
used to sing that song as a kid well we
we used to sing it was part of like our
camp song a chair and then they make
they they didn't let us sing it anymore
so depressing it crazy who wrote that
song some ones that had sadness um and
then the second part to the story is
that the bachelor in paradise cast has
been announced yeah and I'm like annoyed
about one person in particular okay well
I'm gonna go through it because there's
a lot so always the 12 people that start
make it the furthest because they have
the most time to form connections they
have deep roots in the community
they have deep roots in the community
however I just want to say I'm very
grateful that back what so people have
been saying that like they're telling
their boyfriends and like families that
they want to go to camp tous and like it
sounds like a cult like we're like
luring people to the was and talks of
uprooting and starting a community maybe
we are cult leaders that don't make
money that today no ever like amongst
ourselves because we can do this show
anywhere and we're not asking you all to
move with us like we're just saying like
and it's also like I don't want to be in
a cult like I like to be by myself leave
me alone no it's too much pressure
especially to be a cult like we have to
come up with all this look what happened
to nexium right I don't want to go down
that path honestly I think you know
we'll be like assaulting him I'd rather
be on the pond I'd rather go down that
path oh yeah of course the righteous
path you pay for your sins okay I just
want to say before we you know what
we're talking about today we're all over
the place it's fine that's why people
like it's better I'd rather be all over
the place and then have a word of our
worst shows and looking count-out and we
just look at each other like that was
terrible that only happened like I know
one show is from the old show that I
think was the worst show we ever did
well I have amnesia I can barely
remember you it was like a random show
in November and we talked about nothing
no like this is the thing when you do
the show every day maybe that's why our
shows have been so good because we've
been like missing some days where it's
like sometimes you just need a break and
sometimes you just need to like be wild
and out and I think it's honestly it's
camcos has got us all four cleansed no
I'm like I'm high on camp toast agreed
and other things okay I just want to say
before we announce the cast I am so
excited and happy that Becca Martinez is
not part of the original oh my god I
didn't even think about that but you'll
be the first one touching down in
paradise okay first up we have you know
she won't to have problems like the rest
of the girls like Raven used to get so
hot because her hair was so long okay
but do you think that Becca is gonna go
with unshaven armpits like she's been
sporting on her social media no well I
think that she shed I think she's ladies
I think she's a Bachelor is a very old
school and like non progressive in their
production like hairy armpits are not
allowed but she's gonna conform to
society when in her regular life she
goes on that trial yes she fights the
patriarchy during the day but at night
she's out of school I would honestly I
would have a lot of respect for her if
she went up with every arm yes meet you
and they would have to make it
big deal like they do but they make the
smallest things I'm a paradise a big
deal and I really hope that this is one
of those things I think it would
actually like do a lot for a perception
of hairy armpits let's do it okay first
up we have a girl named Angela from
Knicks season I think she went home
night one I'm pretty sure I remember her
I think she was a quote model so what
that's annoying she'll be leaving cast
member for someone who went home and I
went I don't even remember her and
that's back when I watched well I
actually am here for main cast members
someone who went home one night one
because of LaCie padule she went home
night one on Juan Pablo season and she
wound up getting engaged cuz she was so
underrated I don't think you were
talking about a different lady and I'm
like we're not on the same no please I
don't think this girl is next Laci okay
fine next up we have Annalise who has
all these childhood traumas oh yeah I
remember her sure that'll be funny she's
fine yeah um
Astrid lock which is crazy that means
she broke up with her long time well I
know I was thinking the same thing and
her boyfriend
um and Alexis his boyfriend like they
were like a foursome yeah drama
I'm actually really shook I didn't take
enough time to process like how she's
there really fell through the cracks
like in terms of being like one of the
prettiest girls who got like literally
no attention then she had huge boobs but
she did it right because she like went
on The Bachelor she had the fun
experience and got a heart doesn't
follow the heartbreak hundred thousand
followers friends for a lifetime and now
she's going on paradise I feel like she
could mind up engage because she's just
like normal and like you know will fall
in love will say next up the girl of the
moment to Jana Oh oh my god her picture
is so sultry and sexy she is so South
meantime maybe sex with her and if she
gonna host at home early I'll be really
upset not to be a spoiler alert but
someone saw someone
okay a spoiler so if you don't hear so
alert someone saw a Caroline Looney in
the airport like right after they
started filming which means she was like
one of the first people to go home which
is shocking because she's so pretty and
nice well she's not even part of
original cast which shattered I mean
they mean she steps up and steps out no
but she steps in and she gets a road no
yeah you get a rose when you step on
yeah you got a date card
anyways Chelsea the mom that's who I'm
upset about why I really don't like her
I thought she made it way too far on her
season and I thought we were done with
her and I just like honestly I was about
to say something mean but I want I think
I didn't love her on whatever season she
was on this
yeah I know no she's so much no no she
wasn't she was on re-season whatever I
didn't love her but I actually I think
she was a good person a little
misunderstood and she's really pretty I
think she'll actually do really well I
don't like her I'm not here for it
I think she's misunderstood she gives me
like Olivia Creedy vibes I think you're
misunderstood I think I am too me too
but what do you think people understand
about me that's that's misinformation
actually I think what people like know
about you was like exactly who you are
fun-loving go thank you
next up we have the chicken who just got
eliminated David who fell off the bunk
bed I hope there are no bunk beds in
paradise there are well he needs about
music up that's just the words of singer
Gabe I heard like look I actually
watched that episode that was crazy so
much blood and like throughout the next
week's like his eyes just like falling
out no it's crazy okay next up we have
Erik bigger a man who was made for
paradise and like a man who deserves
justice like he really got the short end
of a stick like he has no Instagram
followers and he is like a sad podcast
stop also like different wanted person
who goes on the podcast I've had a
chance with Rachel he never had a chance
of a troll and he never had a chance
with the bachelor like the role of the
bachelor and he really thought he had
real chances with both and to be
disappointed twice is probably so sad
it's more than one man can handle but I
thought we had him on our show and he
was an angel from God and I really like
him and he's hot and really tall
I think he's gonna thrive in paradise me
too grocery store Joe justice everyone
is just like I don't know it's just a
weird how like this I say it's just like
everyone just decides on something and
then runs with it that like grocery
store Joe justice needs justice sure I
hope he brings groceries I wonder they
should have his grocery store supply I
went I bet his grocery stores doing
really well hmm Becca went to it when
you're in Chicago you smell oh my god
yes okay cool does anyone know the name
event grocery store Joe oh and if he
hasn't changed his grocery store to that
yet then he's not into he's missing out
on a branding opportunity um speaking of
branding opportunities John Graham who
was the guy who was eliminated last week
from Becca and he was like the software
developer for venmo so like he has a job
and that's rich
totally oh gosh my iPad is freaking out
because Jordan the model is in paradise
of course he is and honestly he's
hilarious that's it that's um
one at casting who's in tune with what's
necessary because like Jordan is not
what you think he is like you think he's
just like Robbie Hayes like douchey
obsessed with himself but he's also very
funny like I'm really hating the fact
that I wore shorts today like I keep
looking at my phone
just don't let he's like thunder thighs
are just like they're the whole show
just don't look and also you know what
you'll look at this episode in a week
and be like that looks amazing that day
and I felt terrible totally all the time
I went to a doctor yesterday and we were
just like talking and he was like when
did you start Kenny wait and I was like
well like 10 years ago I thought I was
huge and like I look back on pictures
and I was literally on oh so like how do
I know I don't know like when we started
the totus i thought it was like so big
and now I'm bigger so no it's like
perception is everything like I wish I
wear this dress the first week
like when I just watch I can really tell
so you have to realize like in this
moment like just be grateful I'm not 10
pounds of here you're gonna wish that
this you were back in this moment you
know I highly doubt that okay
taxidermist Kendall I can't and I shan't
with her truly I feel the same way about
her that I feel about Chelsea like got
too far she was top three I know for
taxidermy look that's disgusting and
inhumane I just find a good to be family
very very annoying and I don't know why
I can't get behind her Kenny Lena
Justin Kenny and his sweet sweet
daughter I hope he does well I feel like
home he doesn't exploit his daughter
anymore in like FaceTime her live on
television that let her go to school but
honestly like she was old enough to like
yeah he's for him well when you think of
like these people like who go on the
show cuz no one on the show was like
really older than like 35 so when they
have kids you don't think they're older
than like three or four right and he had
like this teenage daughters Gracie okay
Kevin from Bachelor Winter Games who was
dating Ashley I before she got back with
Jairus also speaking about her whenever
games they have that girl from Japan as
like a part of the something as she's
being trained by wells to be the
bartender apparently she's hilarious we
didn't watch winter games but I feel
like I like her yeah me too she's very
quiet
totally crystal thank you honestly I'm
[ __ ] here for crystal like she will
bring some flavor and I feel like she'll
fall in love I'm like so done with like
this gimmicky [ __ ] that ABC grey is
perpetuating but she's not a gimmick
like she's just she's really that crazy
yeah and she definitely worked out like
super hard for it to speech body so like
I look forward to seeing it my favorite
part so intense like that's like she's
not baking my favorite part of bachelor
in paradise is like a seeing how
everyone's hair fairs in the Mexico heat
seeing who can they control their sweat
the best and then also seeing who has
the best body in a bathing suit
exactly and like who can do really good
makeup given the circumstances no
there's like a natural look it's very
difficult and in the heat they have fans
ever like there's literally you could
not pay me two million dollars to go on
about our matter like you're literally
blending your contour with sweat yeah
it's kind of a great settings where
people that like that you think did it
well
Amanda Stanton always looks good yeah
and she had long hair that is not sweat
she does well she's so small and frail
like for her to probably hold yeah boys
are always sweating through their shirts
right but Jade looked beautiful she wore
no makeup
you know like Sohni hair took like a
hardhead on paradise ladies brief moment
that she was there
lace grid she was here oh so it's like
frizzy and poofy and like you just kind
of jump in the pool at that point
honestly like to where I can update
Alexis did good too even though she was
she was there for a long time and she
like never dated anyone know cuz like
I'm pretty sure she was dating someone
and they just like needed her except her
around for fun jasmine has an amazing
body and Jasmine's hair stayed in good
shape
yeah also raven no Ravens hair was a
little wild was it so long you got to
get a haircut before about charm
paradise no or you just have to like
having I would go with like a an updo
the whole time like a green well now
that I have this new chin I'm thinking I
can rocking updo you should try it it's
the most liberating thing they had a
wedding with an updo like you like if
you had an updo last night your night
would have been so different
I know okay anyways Nick's best us from
Becca's season he was um he's a lawyer I
think not a lawyer no it's like so crazy
no this is I really got so into it I
mean either it's not funny like you had
to be there and then nishan Norris who
was on re-season I do not remember her
but she's wearing a very toasty top so
for that reason she has my vote yes
she's pretty she is well I look forward
to watching this and - yeah oh yeah and
Colton oh I guess he comes he comes he
that'll be so like ground shaking like
everyone's be like oh he's hot he's
already taken I'm I just gotta wait
we're stone
oh I think there's one more there's
actually two more because that was a
double-header of our day's news next up
this is a very weird story the Kim
Kardashian was quote obligated to make a
Ukrainian billionaire famous after and
promote her music career after she
bought the star seventeen million dollar
bel-air mansion
so apparently Kim and Kanye broke real
estate records when they sold their Bel
Air I mentioned to a Ukrainian
billionaire for a mammoth seventeen
point eight million dollars but it has
been claimed that along with the mammoth
price tag wow they were just loving this
word man oh yeah it's hard to say it's a
great word yes
Acton splashed out for the property
there was also an important clause that
reality Queen Kim needed to help make
her famous so like no one would buy this
house and the only people that water
like Russian oligarchs like needed
American Fame and they got the right guy
for the job
totally the brunette beauty and her
rapper bow so the 10,000 square foot
properties silicon valley-based
philanthropist marina back in November
making a whopping eight million dollar
profit however was reported that Acton
is a huge fan of Kim and his dreams of
becoming a successful singer with the
socialite allegedly paying more than the
property was worth due to the curvaceous
Stars connection genius I literally
can't wait for like the Instagram story
I'd like Kim getting her makeup done
listening to like this Russian what is
she
ah Ukrainian Ukrainian like pop music in
the back nobody looks good or like just
like posting with her yeah like what am
i guard ass
I wonder if she'll have to do hashtag ad
probably the FCC will come for her the
FCC is on her case the FCC football
FCC's football right no FCC is I'm the
financial one sec oh no that's the
sports no as he's definitely like FBI
money an SEC is also Jordan Rogers yes
that's it also channel for sports but
FCC is like the football not football
football club FTC goes after Instagram
ads but only real like Kim yeah I've
never been I've never been it oh come
what I'm a totally JLo no so you gonna
find but you will buy by the guidelines
of course a hash tag ad that's it and
you really don't have to use that paid
partnership thing at the top according
to the FTC yeah isn't it crazy I know
but Instagram just like wants to ruin
our lives
I think Instagram just like once could
you have a lid
but of control are the Wild West of
Instagram sponsorship FCC is
communications like TV and radio that
sounds wrong
oh maybe FCC is like advertisement a No
that's what the Federal Trade Commission
cuz that's their also talk about FTC and
madmen because there was FCC okay
whatever maybe maybe we just made it up
what's that story the last story is
about a girl our favorite girl Megan
okay we have some but she's definitely
favorite when you said favorite girls
everyone say Kim but we had just said
Kim favorite girl Jeff Lee Megan Marco
favorite girl bebe Rexha and I'm kidding
I don't even never spoken about bebe
Rexha I love the news she's not a news
maker no not not yet Megan is accused of
making another faux pas during last
night's Buckingham Palace reception
everybody working her but can you spot
it it's that she's not with her legs
crossed Jarama her legs are so thin to
the point that it's I'm worried for her
you know she's she's so thin but like
I'm sure she just has so much like on
her place look how is a royal so Megan
Margolis at like this she has so much on
her plate yet nothing at all no of
course the Queen sits like this honestly
I think that's the one thing I couldn't
handle about being royal is like always
having to like the way that you were
sitting was fine you know I know but
like the posture thing oh I'm slashing
this whole time yeah posture is tough
for anyone okay are you done because I
have something I wanna talk that's
pretty much it I can get into the
details of her cross-legged shame but
before we wrap up for today there's
something I need to talk about take your
time I watch a lot of TV yesterday
because I was doing some catch-up
research and I have a blanket statement
I would like to say okay below Jack - on
TV and you have to watch it
which one med I don't know if the
regulars had the one with Malia
well she's not there anymore why she was
too much of a shoot starter and what do
you mean it's like oh pretty and
everyone's day there no but she was
playing both sides and it turns out she
had a relationship with a chef before
the job yep and then she realized that
he's a douche and she got was the good
guy that he wasn't a good guy though
yes he was no that's what they wanted
you to think well who's on it now it's a
bunch of the same people and already
people Anna I don't know she was getting
justice served for her too
I don't need justice for her she was no
sorry she's getting her ass handed to
her okay um but she's dating the cutest
bosun who was on about trapezoid with
Rachel so last night he weighs Hannah
yeah and they're like so cute like I
feel like I'm in middle school it's like
literally they gonna be kissing booth
vibes what she's like 40 no I know she's
like 24 it's like a big deal that he's
Bo's in it's so good and they had this
group of people come on that like I'm
really upset about and I want to go on a
rant on they were Jewish and they were
kosher and they were some of the most
obnoxious people I've ever met in my
life and they made us look so bad and
she's like us I know that like a lot of
our listeners like come from areas there
aren't a lot of Jewish people and I just
need to have a blanket statement it's
like please don't let honey and her crew
of impossible patrons speak for us we're
nice people we're good people we're
generous people what were they doing oh
my god they were so obnoxious like they
ordered Don Julio 1942 oh and they got
the wrong tequila and like literally
before they left dock they got new one
by five o'clock before they left matter
literally every ten seconds it's a 1942
here it's a 1942 here like there's still
tequila like relax
every time they ordered one of them was
a vegan one of the most kosher in the
rest I'm Warren kosher but like he was
literally making different meals for
everyone and everyone was so I'm
naturally the steak is called like just
like next-level annoying like wanted to
do things at the most inopportune times
dinner was at nine o'clock didn't show
up till 11:30 like what so rude like
that I think that's not Jewish
no it's so late and likeness but there
was one like a really Jewish thing that
happened and like honestly it was so
funny like for lunch he made a Chinese
chicken salad and they ate it and they
thought it was like the appetizer and
Vic that was it and they were like no
we're starving you want more food that's
funny that's pretty Jewish
yeah that was highly accurate that's a
good show like we should go on it I know
but then I was thinking like just this
you still have to pay for it like I
think to charter a yacht for like two or
three days it's like a hundred grand but
when you do it on the show it's way
cheaper cuz like your life isn't your
own and also like they're not really
working that hard like yeah because
they're like like filming yeah so you
get like a discounted experience but you
also like you in a bathing suit on TV
which no but you don't you got to be in
your own like Beach where what you guys
you know what I enjoy and go swimming
and like if you play if you watch a girl
with no jobs YouTube of how to maintain
a chubby physique in the warm weather
then you're all sort of set that's true
thank you for reminding me okay so some
housekeeping in Athens do you want to
announce your guests so coat
for Chicago tomorrow morning that's an
exciting lineup so tomorrow as you know
we have Darren carp from Bravo and I'm
so excited to pick her brain and then
Friday total change of place we have
born Bostick the skinny confidential
hosting with me and like that's just
gonna be people are obsessed I'm
obsessed with like a beauty
she's such a beauty guru expert and I'm
gonna come with a laundry list of items
businesswomen - she's everything and
she's so beautiful and cute and nice and
I'm so excited to take her brain you
should have Michael come on that's like
a guest and like bringing the third
chair oh my god cuz we have a shared
throne anyways it's gonna be really fun
we'll have guest cards up where you can
put your questions and I will ask them
do you don't worry I'm heading to
Chicago tomorrow so I'm gonna see all of
you guys there is like 10 tickets left
for this final show the sixth show I can
we've been doing six shows on Saturday
night in Rosemont I'm really excited and
then we're back and for next week we're
doing a show Monday Tuesday then it's
July 4th so everyone has to get drunk
and by the way I just found out that I
think you can see the fireworks to my
apartment really if you want to come
over and like use my apartment while I'm
gone
oh no I have I have a good plan for it
Triforce because I face the river and
they're on 34th Street like that's right
by me no that's really nice I know
that's really Sophia we'll see them oh
no he won't be coming with me of the
Hamptons Oh fun and I got him a special
collar for ticks because the last time
he was there he got so many checks he's
ticky yeah um that'll be so nice I know
Wow okay so you'll be back Monday
that'll be really fun have fun in
Chicago thank you oh we have patreon
update our fourth episode we forgot to
tell you cuz we were too busy talking
about cam toast is up it's all about New
York City all of our recommendations we
ran eat where to drink where to shop and
we're good enough to go difficult
episode to film because like I deliver
to Rack my break
it's very hard it is and so people
always ask us for recommendations I'm so
glad there's one place we can send them
to that has everything where you want to
go where you should eat if you're
watching your weight if you're not
watching your weight if you want to get
drunk if you want to get drunk
cheaply sides if you want to drink
outside if you want to get drunk
elevated if you want to get drunk and
good light what a good trick okay
drunken bass man if I get drunk on the
ground floor we have all different
levels and then we will be recording our
fists patreon episode today so if you're
not in the toast after dark group as a
page remember please join and give us
all of your suggestions because we work
for you the morning toast
is amazing the morning toast is Melania
morning show that a lot sorry I'm sorry
God the morning chose to take two but we
chose them take two the more you chose
is amazing it's the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time and we live
stream on Facebook and YouTube so make
sure you subscribe just on YouTube and
like us on Facebook and then we're also
available for those commuters in the
podcast app at the morning toast make
sure you leave a five star review about
how that girl and strip shirt has the
most amazing voice and that girl in the
yellow shirt has just the most amazing
complexion and that's all we got for you
I will see you guys on Monday Jackie
we'll see you tomorrow with our co-hosts
and I'll see you guys in Chicago bye
you